nothing against them but it's a minority
of unhappy viewers most people watching
the show
um when Juliet realizes that her dad uh
I'll get i'll get Terry just talk about
this when she realizes that her dad
didn't turn her mom in and he wasn't
what destroyed their lives and she
forgives him
and says you know he's like I miss her
every day and she's like me too and I
love you and and they're holding each
other you can't get that moment without
everything that came before it the
flashbacks with you know even with
knowing what Allison went through with
having her birth control taken out and
knowing that this doctor is complicit in
that system but he wasn't you know part
of the problem that got um his wife in
trouble like you you have to invest in a
whole bunch of different little threads
to get that moment and when I get back
in and think about the season it's
moments like that